retour donc ici à washington l'émotion
bien sûr et moins intense cas à new york
le bilan fait état d'à peu près 180
morts pour l'instant mais bien entendu
on a ressenti comme un choc très fort de
voir des cibles militaires ou civiles
prises d'assaut par les terroristes
regardez ces images d'abord ces images
du pentagone tourné quelques heures
quelques minutes même après le
bombardement par les confier elles sont
commentés par etienne leenhardt et puis
on se retrouvera à côté de ce qu'on
appelle ici le bunker mardi 11 septembre
dernier il est un peu plus de neuf
heures du matin l'épaisse colonne de
fumée noire qui s'échappe du pentagone
vient illustrer l'inimaginable
cet énorme forteresse le bâtiment que
l'on proposé d'être le mieux défendu de
tous les états unis vient d'être
éventrée par un avion de lit cinq jours
plus tard avec les soft au
rez-de-chaussée de l'ale qui a été
touché
l'explosion du boeing d'american
airlines bourré de carburant puisqu'il
venait de décoller d'un aéroport plus
proches à tout frais sur son passage
à l'heure qu'il est sur les 180
personnes officiellement portées
disparues
ici à washington onze seulement ont pu
être identifiés si la structure résiste
l'on reconstruira au plus vite la partie
endommagée
les vingt mille militaires qui chaque
jour travaillent ici dans le centre
nerveux du système de défense le plus
sophistiqué du monde garderont toutefois
longtemps et comme toute l'amérique
le sentiment désormais d'être vulnérable
en